i have a similar experience to one of  your jokes i don't think i've ever told  you this  you did what now no no no no i didn't do  you did  literally what did what what happened  well  you know every kid you know in their day  and age walks in on their parents  um you didn't see me you walked in on us  once once am i just finding about this  now  live yeah neither of you actually know  about this  it never it never it never came out i  was just like i was just hit it  how old were you 18 my senior year in  high school oh  no oh yeah that was like yeah i did  knock on the door  assuming you guys were still asleep uh  we weren't no  i could do my version of of the joke of  when you walk into your parents  yeah i'm sure i i think i could do it  really well actually but you don't have  to  you